[Music]
so just like an athlete has to get up
right before a game and figure out a way
how to psych themselves out to face the
opponent you also need to figure out a
way to psych yourself out when you face
the opponent on a daily basis and not
only yourself but also do with your
teammate because as an entrepreneur you
also got a team that you're driving so
today in this video I'm going to talk
about how you can drive you what drives
you and what drives the people on your
team and prior to me getting into the
video if you got any questions thoughts
comment comment below if you haven't
subscribed to the channel be sure to
click on the subscribe button so you can
watch other videos and join the
notification squad so the videos come
out to you the moment it comes out so ok
so let's get right into it I've done a
couple other videos on this topic that I
suggest you watch as well one of them is
the evolution of your why where I talk
about how a person goes through you know
being in the survival mode all you want
to do is pay your bills so you can find
a place to live then status you want to
have a nice car then freedom you want to
make a lot of money a million so you can
be free to make the decisions you want
to make them purpose something bigger
right I'm not talking about that today
but I suggest you watch it the other one
is how to get the best out of your sales
force and that's something with your
sales people on what you're doing with
them today's gonna be getting a little
bit deeper into what drives human beings
what drives you what drives me a couple
books that were written about this
Daniel pink wrote about this in a book
called Drive where he says autonomy
mastery and purpose and you can study a
little bit more about what 20 Robin says
with this six things that make people
take certainty uncertainty significance
love and connection growth and
contribution my suggestion watch these
two videos and study these two books but
having said that let me get right into
four areas that I want to talk about
that drives people under each of these
four areas I have different bullet
points total it's gonna end up being
around 20 of them some of them are gonna
be more some of them are gonna be less
but when you sit yourself I'm gonna give
you a PDF at the end I want you to score
it at at least 20 and ask yourself this
really drives me I really could care
less about this you know what I this
really makes me think is this really me
and then ask your loved ones ask your
spouse your boyfriend your girl
friend your mom your dad people that
work closely with you and say score me
here real quick and tell me which one
you think it is someone that knows
you're not critical not gonna be fully
positive and everything's perfect with
you they're just gonna tell you look
this is what typically drives you I just
want you to know great no problem you
kind of get an idea to be self-aware
then take the same scorecard and do with
the people that you work with on a daily
basis and you know what happens if you
get to a point that you don't have an
answer port this is the time where you
got to have a sit-down and figure out
what drives them so you can get the best
set of your team so let's get into it
number one advancement there's a lot of
people that are simply driven by
advancing which means what I want to hit
my next promotion so if you sit down
with one of your teammates and someone
tells you I just want to hit my next
promotion great you now have the
motivation now you need to give them the
direction here's the next three things
you need to do that your next promotion
this is what you need to change about
your schedule this is what needs to
happen with the way you're working right
now the amount of calls you're making an
amount of activity you're doing it's not
gonna get you to your next promotion I
need you to read these five books I need
you to go out there and do this then you
only get your next promotion perfect god
I'm gonna go work on it because they're
driven by what's next another one is
completing a task Mike that is a task
driven person all he will if he starts
something he has to finish it so if you
know someone's driven by that you break
it down so how far along are you with
your task what is left what are you
gonna do what are your dates what are
the things that you're gonna plan on
hitting this part and that leads me in
to point number three which is meeting a
deadline there are people that are
driven by deadlines it's due by the 31st
I'm gonna hit about the 31st web a
person that works you're Mara and I kid
about this this guy is gonna give you
the product by the deadline but he works
till the last second to get you the
deadline but here's the key he's gonna
give it to you by the deadline even if
it means he's working Sunday throughout
the night gets no sleep because it's to
Monday morning 8 o'clock he'll get it to
you he's driven by a deadline so if you
know that person's driven my deadline
guess what give him more deadlines maybe
move the deadline sooner instead of
given up till the 31st give until the
28th or the 15 change the deadline you
can change the deadline because you know
they're gonna get it done number 4
reaching a milestone as a team there are
people that say look what is the next
thing we need to do as a company what is
the next thing we need to do as a team
I want to go do that your everybody on a
team is not necessarily gonna be I want
to be able to be the MVP the biggest
score that this I need all the attention
there are people that say look I want to
help the team get to the next level but
they want to see a company and a team
advance there are people that work out
of a company and they get bored out of
their mind
because the numbers are not growing and
they're not advancing and you ludo lose
those people because they're driven by
reaching the next milestone as a company
so what is the next thing we're reaching
for said there need to ask yourself am I
constantly giving the team our next
milestone as a company if I'm not then
I'm not getting the best of the people
here that are driven by the next
milestone let's talk about the next one
this next one I have out as selfish but
it's not necessarily selfish it's not a
you know there are certain words that
you know culturally we see as a negative
like cult we are very uncomfortable with
the word cult but we're very comfortable
with the word culture right we're very
comfortable using certain words selfish
there's a lot of great performers who do
very well for teams who are very selfish
in sports there's people that are
selfish who do very very well and they
help teams win championships but this is
not the selfish you're thinking where
it's kind of like it's mine it's mine it
has to be all mine no this is a person
that says hey I like nice things
I want to lose Vuitton purse I'm not
driven by Louis Vuitton purse but there
are people that are I want a six
thousand dollar suit I want to be able
to have 20 different watches in my
closet great I want to be able to have
the nice cars I like the nice cars I
want to be able to have this court
there's nothing wrong with that but
sometimes if you speak this language to
somebody that's not driven by lifestyle
you cannot drive that person it's not
everybody next recognition there are
people that are driven by recognition so
how do you drive people that are driven
by recognition you taste it you kind of
get a feel I gave him a little bit of
recognition he blew up man he wants to
get more I gave her a little bit she's
all lit up but I give it to this person
this guy wasn't driven by this but then
I talked to this guy about what his life
could look like what kind of a house he
wants what kind of a car he wants what
he wants to do for his family and the
kind of places he wants to live he was
lit up cuz that guy's driven my
lifestyle and any of security
they're people that selfishly they want
to be secure there are people that marry
others because they feel safe and secure
when they marry this person security is
also selfish feature by the way selfish
quality again it's not a bad thing I
want to live many of you live in a city
and a country because you feel safer
there
that's not a bad quality but there are
people that are driven by this you need
to be able to speak that language with
them next madness this is my favorite
category because this is the part where
you don't see a lot in these books here
a lot of books that they're all about
positive motivation all this other stuff
they don't really get into the madness
side of performers and you know for
myself having nearly 6000 sales people
in our company I see the madness all
over the place and I kind of go through
it with you so you kind of get and
understand which one it is number 8
there are people who do very well with
having an opposition very well they want
an opposition they want an enemy they
want somebody that they got to take out
because they're driven by that there are
others are like I don't really care
about that but there are those that are
driven by opposition so if you have that
this is when you hear coaches where they
go out there and say hey today before we
go and play this game football game I
want you to hear what Steve and I Smith
said about you and they put it up I want
you to see the game what happened last
year when they faced these guys they
they look what they did I want you to
see what happened over him what they say
about us in a paper opposition and it
seems like oh my gosh wait till I pop
you when you come down the lane
that's opposition that works in certain
environments and certain individuals
number nine competition if there's
people that are driven by competition
the way you figure this out is by
creating an environment where there's
competition to be done okay not
combative what competition to be done
leaders bulletins data brackets you know
this OP is going against this person and
then you see oh my goodness when this
person was facing this person all of a
sudden I saw sight of performance I've
never seen her before men she is so
competitive he is so competitive you
then bring out the best out of her or
him by knowing how competitive that
person is number ten there are people
madness that are driven by control I
want to control my
space I want to control what I'm doing
next I want to perform so much that
every decision I make in my life I
control so what can I do to have that
control
so as you're driving the person you're
leading you are telling them what they
can do to put themselves in a position
to be fully control of what they're
doing that's what they like but if you
don't speak that language to them you're
not gonna be able to drive them that
could be you by the way watching this
number 11 power and fame there's a lot
of performers that are driven by power
and fame many of them there's a lot of
people that are driven by hey I want to
go make my money because after making my
money I want to go around for governor I
want to go run for office I want to go
around for this because I want to be
able to have the power the influence to
be on the cover of Time magazine and
make some big decisions and I want to be
famous
perfect now somebody might say and this
is what some sales leaders do that is
absolutely pathetic and they'll say well
you know it's not a noble thing to you
know Fame and all this stuff no let me
just get the best out of you if that's
what drives you let's get it what do you
want to do and now at the same time
while you're doing all this stuff you're
teaching hopefully the right values and
the right principles that you're not
creating somebody that's out of this
world that you know it doesn't listen to
anybody and thinks they know everything
you you can lead them and direct them
and do anything with them you're not
trying to create a narcissistic cycle
although they do well as well in
business you do want to tame that old
lady but you can't fully do it you want
to teach those right values and
principles but at the same time hey I
don't mind somebody that's driven by
then here's number 12 you heard Barbara
Corcoran say it from shark tank proven
others wrong I don't know if you saw the
interview with Barbara and I when she
said my boyfriend at the time told me
you will never succeed without me she
left built the company sold it for 66
million dollars and in the interview
this is what she says she says honestly
this is probably not healthy I should
have probably seen a shrink about it but
I told him wait till you see what I'm
gonna do to you and boom now she's on
Shark Tank that boyfriend has to watch
for on Shark Tank every day someone's
gonna say what's not your ex what's not
your ex what's in that wreck
yes you better believe
and that's madness number 13 they need
to avoid embarrassment let me explain
what I mean by this need to avoid
embarrassment you see a person who is
about to give a talk to a group of
people sometimes the need that the meet
a man I do not want to be embarrassed
I'm gonna have so much anxiety when I
perform they over prepare themselves
into delivering that talk you have
somebody that's expected to perform and
hit a certain number they are so worried
about the next board meeting of them not
reaching their numbers because they
don't want to be embarrassed amongst
their peers that they're gonna go above
and beyond and work certain days to make
sure they reach that milestone so if you
don't know that about the individual
you're not gonna get the best out of him
now somebody's gonna again they're gonna
watch this and say how bad is that to
embarrass and all this other stuff
listen everybody woke up this morning
putting clothes on because you don't
want to be embarrassed so let's not act
like you know this this is such a out of
the ordinary topic it's just the truth
and this is why I put it into madness
category 14 mastery I want to be a
master at what I do a long time ago when
I got started in this business I told
myself Pat you've never mastered
anything never I was a body builder but
I never mastered it I never won mr.
universe or mr. Olympia you know I was
into all these other things wood stocks
and bonds and all these things but I
didn't master it I was on to all the
every other sports that I wasn't never
mastered it I said when I get into the
insurance space and building the sales
teams I want to master this space I want
to be a master in this space it takes
around 15 to 20 years to do it by the
way right
not everybody's driven by that a few are
this is why you say I am going to do
this so many times until I master the
game of business and entrepreneurship
I'm gonna do this so much I'm gonna
immerse myself so much until I master
this you may not be driven by that but a
few people are and that still meets the
category of madness because if you want
to be a master of anything if masters
publicly told you their schedules you
would be frightened of them you wouldn't
be excited it wouldn't be a motivational
video it wouldn't be where some people
my gosh I also want to be a master it
would scare too
wrap out of 99.99% of people if they
knew what it really took to become a
master because it's absolutely crazy and
insanity the way they perform work hours
to focus diligence you know while the
other guy is doing this and he thinks I
worked so hard today he's just getting
started the Masters like dude what are
you talking about
my brains been going all day since I got
up at 4 o'clock so but some people are
driven by that some of you got scared
after even me hearing me the last 60
seconds on what I said about mastery
number 15 be the best break records it's
not necessarily mastery I just want to
break all the records what's the record
I want to be the all time selling person
to my company I want to break the record
for this I want to break the record for
that what are the records cuz I want to
be the best I want to be the leader the
decade I want to be the MVP you know for
five years and I want to be the best of
the best I want to be able to walk into
him with all my other peers from other
companies and they say oh my gosh she's
in the room the best of the best I want
to break all those records who is it
not everybody's in that category you
find one person like this oh my goodness
can you imagine what kind of a company
and build you give me a couple of people
like this we can take over the world
together
a purpose last but not lease history
they're driven by history I was in an
interview recently with Matt Manero Matt
came over here he's got his own podcast
and he asked me a question about
creating content and all this other
stuff he said some really nice words
about what we do on value taming you
know and then he said so what it what is
the purpose of value to him and I said
listen I can look at someone's eyes and
I can listen to three of your videos and
content and I can tell if it's driven by
money lifestyle all of that and that's
easy that's cool there's nothing wrong
with that's the concept of capitalism
you can make the money and get the
things that you want that's the
lifestyle part that's the power and fame
you know celebrity status type of deal
but then purpose there's history this
outlives you when you die I can name you
a hundred billionaires that you would
never know because they're dead I can
name you many billionaires that no one
knows that they're dead why because what
they did was purely money it wasn't
necessarily all his
we see this lives a long time right some
people are driven by history
some people are driven by serving others
I want to help how can I help how can I
help the community what can we do to
make money so we can take the money and
give it to the community what can we do
to help this person become better
honestly let me tell you why I love
working at this companies because those
six people they're in their 20s I'm 42 I
remember when I was in my 20s I want to
serve them because I feel I can help
them get to the next level serving
others no problem Johnny I want you to
go and run this department because those
six people are relying on you if you
know this you know how to drive them if
you have somebody that's driven by
history you know how to speak to them if
change what I mean by driven by change
Mario and I were in my office earlier
today about an hour ago I said Mario
we're about to shoot this episode he
said yes I said I want you to look at
the painting in my office and he looks
at it and he goes through it one by one
by one I said before we shoot this video
I want you to tell me what two pockets
driven by what is MLK driven by what's
Milton Friedman driven by what's the
Shah of Iran driven by what was he
driven by how about how about Senna
how about Lincoln how about Kennedy how
about Einstein what are they driven by
tell Mario well you spend a lot of hours
maybe what am i driven by what are you
driven by and we're going through with
this right and the conversation comes
you know sex and such persons driven by
change what does change mean I want to
change the climate I want to change the
way people view Millennials I want to
change the way people view the Hispanic
community I want to change the way
people view the african-american I want
to change the way people view Middle
Easterners I want to change the way
people view sixteen-year-old
entrepreneurs I want to change the way
people see me in this company because
the last company I was just a regular
guy I want to come and you'd be somebody
special I want to change I want to be
part of change that's some people 19 is
impact I want to make an impact how can
I come and be an impact on this team be
an impact in the community be an impact
in the state be an impact in a nation
being impact internationally last but
not least 20 is enlightenment two
different kinds of enlightenment we're
talking about here one is how can I get
myself to be more enlightened by getting
information so I can help make better
decisions so I can help make better
decisions with the team so I can help
become better at directing the
enlightenment could be somebody that
gets analytics and says hey I looked at
this and I've been studying this for the
last three months I noticed every
Wednesdays we have a bad day but on
Fridays we do very well and I looked at
this last week that we enlightened I'm
studying myself to see what's going on
over here so if you have somebody that's
like that give them the right books give
them the right things to watch to study
and all of a sudden they're going
they're going they're going boom they
get it off to the races right but if you
don't give them those things for them to
have that click as you're speaking to
them they're not gonna have that click
once they do that person can start
performing and helping everybody else
view things easier make decisions
smoother and just say all this make
sense you know you're right John yes
we're enlightened as a group together
right so now having said that you got 20
points here I'm giving you a PDF so
click on a link below to go to my
website it's gonna either gonna be in
the comment section or it's gonna be in
the description section if you don't see
just go to Patrick video be calm type
the same title Patrick med David calm
right here put on this title and the
search will take you to it
I want you to print out this PDF when
you subscribe to our newsletters when
you print out this PDF go through it
with yourself on what drives you okay
ranked the top three then go through
with the people that are you're leading
and ask them and speak to them and see
what they tell you and once you have
that and you now have a list of three
five ten people in your organization and
you're you know staff your executive
your sales people on how to drive them
now you know how to drive everybody
collectively and at that point remember
how I said before you know it just like
an athlete has to prepare themselves
before they go into a game until how to
face the opponent this is also for you
to be able to put the team together
properly where all of a sudden every
cylinder is just gone and you go from
being a 4 cylinder engine to an 8
cylinder engine to v12 running on 12
cylinders it's very tough when you have
12 cylinders going simultaneously it's
tough to compete in against a car like
that especially when the driver knows
where they're going anything and
everything you want within the bracket
of you're in the industry you're in
could pretty much be yours if you have
some of these things being taking place
and bother we keep this amount it's a
lot of work this isn't like oh my
gosh I can just go figure it out you're
gonna make so many mistakes with us
until you figure this out you're gonna
make so many mistakes with reading
somebody else in a different way but
eventually to intuition will come to you
and you'll figure out a way how to get
better at it so having said that having
said that having said that questions
thoughts comments comment below and if
you ever subscribe to the channel click
on the subscribe button take everybody
bye-bye